life itself is directed by Steve James
it's a documentary about the life and
times of film critic Roger Ebert based
off of his memoirs also called life
itself in regards to people's opinions I
think a documentary can be the most
widely varying simply because you have
to have at least some interest in the
subject to really love a documentary yes
there are documentaries where you can go
in knowing nothing about it and become
fascinated by it and that shows how good
a documentary can be sometimes
documentaries can actually reach beyond
someone who does not have an interest in
say McDonald's I can tell you that after
I saw supersize me I did not eat
McDonald's for two whole years it's
honestly true that film had such an
impact on me and documentaries can do
that the really good ones can life
itself is a documentary that I think is
extremely important for people who love
film or just people who are interested
in knowing about someone who really
loves movies and seeing the impact that
he had on so many people around him
because Roger Ebert is a film critic
that inspired me greatly during his life
I always wanted to talk about movies I
always wanted to make films and even
when I wasn't reviewing films like I am
now I was still reading Roger Ebert's
reviews because his reviews were able to
reach beyond that wall that so many
critics put up around themselves where
you feel like they're impenetrable like
you just can't really figure out what's
going on and he or she's mine because
they're up on a tower
you know I'm better than you I didn't
have an experience with the audience I'm
just kind of reporting my thoughts on
this film I didn't feel enthralled I'm
not going to use I or myself or any of
those type of words in my review I'm
just gonna kind of do a news report on
what I experienced but I won't actually
let you know that I experienced anything
that's how I feel when I read a lot of
film critics reviews nowadays I never
felt that with Ebert and what this
documentary explored so well was his
effect on his family particularly Chaz
Ebert and just how determined he was to
live and enjoy life and see as many
films as he could I was actually very
surprised to learn a lot of the things I
learned about his upbringing in the way
he used to be I honestly did not know
that he suffered from alcoholism that
was news to me and there were a lot of
things that I learned about the way he
viewed himself in his relationship
especially with Siskel that really
surprised me those guys really did not
get along very well at first they had a
very difficult relationship for a while
and it made for some great sparring
chemistry when you watch the television
show and I was not expecting to have
actual footage of him in the hospital I
did not know that this was filmed during
his life I had no idea about that so
that was actually very shocking to see
and a little hard to watch
and that was one of the aspects of the
film that really surprised me I would
say my only disappointing thing was that
it didn't really delve that much into
the art of film criticism and that would
have been something I would have liked
to have seen more about but I can tell
that wasn't really the purpose of the
movie it was more about his life and how
he lived it and the people around him
that were affected by him but I would
have liked to have learned a little bit
more of his specific approach of
filmmaking and not just he won a
Pulitzer Prize he was on a TV show I
just wanted a little bit more about the
art of film criticism but that is a
minor complaint amongst a heap of praise
about this individual about his life and
how inspiring he was to people like
myself I'm gonna give life itself a B+ I
think it's a very good documentary it's
not one of the best documentaries I've
ever seen
but I do think that it explores roger
ebert's life very successfully it's
going to be opening in theaters on July
4th and video-on-demand on July 4th so
even if you don't have a theater near
you seeing it you can check it out on
the Internet and I hope you guys do
because it is worth your time as always
guys thank you so much for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]